Từ thái này, nhằm thực hiện chí thiết mối ngoài của tụi tưởng gây khám xe khoải định kỳ trong người dân
Đông thời phục vụ xây dựng hồ sơ xức khoải định tử và khoảng lý xức khoải toàn ra
Theo yêu cầu của khủy bánh dân thành phố chiming các cơ quan đến vị và giá sốt
Lập dành sách nếu đọc vui xử ý tế trước ngày bước thảo tảm
Nể đông vụ giữ liệu linh nên tàng khoảng lý xức khoải cộng đồng
Vì ở khám xức khoải phải thực hiện đúng quy định của lột ăn toàn về xin đầu đồng
yêu cầu bảo đảnh lỗi dung khám xe khoải được thực hiện đầy đủ
Theo có khám xe khoải đúng với người tử đúng người tạm tội chở lên của bụi tế
Không tự ý các giảnh lỗi dung khám hoặc thay thế vằng các dành mục khám không tương đường
Mào đạm chứ lượng đánh giá thành trả xe khoải và hiệu quả quản lý xe khoải và lỗ đậu
Sau khi hành tất cả đơn vị và tập nhật kết quả khám đến hệ thống
Và báo cáo về sự ý tế trong vòng bán ai để theo dõi và giám sát
Đủ với giám nghiệp, lên đoàn láo đậu thành phố chiming được giáo trị đạo công đoàn
Các tập, phối hợp người sự giống láo đậu tổ chức khám xức khoải đình kì bảo đảnh
Đấy đủ, nỗi dung thặc quy định và hoàn thành chức ngày 3 mũ thống người
Theo ui bán nha dân thành phố chiming, người đứng đầu các cầu quan đơn vị, điểm phương
Phải chiếu trách giảnh về kết quả trình khai khám xức khoải đình kì
Đủ với cán bộ công chức, viền trước và người láo đậu thuộc phạm vi khỏe lý